- And I heard you actually hurt yourself
in the first number.
- [Derek] I did.
- And then had to bandage
yourself up and keep going.
- Listen, I just finished
like a 56 city tour,
out on stage for two hours nonstop
and then the very first
move of the special
I came out and did like a
little James Brown split
and I ripped my hamstring.
(Kelly gasps)
Yeah and I did that with a (yells).
(audience laughs)
♪ Ain't no business like show business ♪
You gotta keep going, right?
- You just kept going
like Beyonce, all right.
- Taped it up with duct tape
and then just kept goin'
and honestly, you know,
luckily you can't really tell
but I definitely, the
tears rolling down my eyes
while I'm smiling.
Ladies and gentlemen.
- I'm so happy about Christmas!
(Julianne cries)
So happy!
And you also released a song, right?
A new song, like an
anthem for 2020, right?
- Yeah, you know 2020's coming up,
it's a beginning of a new decade
and there's a song called "Say
It Now" and it's out there.
It's about sort of acting
in the moment, you know,
saying it right now.
There's no time like the present.
We're often like, someday I'll do this,
someday I'll do that.
There's a good expression that says
the path of someday leads
to a town called Nowhere.
Right, we keep putting it off.
So it's sorta like, let's do it right now.
So yeah.
- All right, all right!